I could they put the hashtag also I like
the show II anxiety you're gonna feel
okay I know they're orange but this is
almost vertical if you never use it
those are the last things you need right
now those are very unimportant to the
tent
why is it doing it by so why I feel like
just the matrix per second dot what are
you why are you i want to zip it up zip
to tena know what other thing what stuff
yeah I'm gonna show people the natural
beauty and then we'll come back and show
how far you guys
[Music]
okay keep showing them the other day I
asked me good loan for love it so it's a
great tip no no I'm just praying Oh Oh
in my sleep haha whoa
oh no it's hard oh my god let's do this
that goes in there okay
no it works yeah look
oh you think you did it
[Music]
oh goodness hot would come okay
Hilda you don't want to stack up a
little better compare matter you don't
need the big guys yet all the one on
yeah why I mean decide no I see this
working very well
ah kidding no you [ __ ] I don't use yes
we're gonna have to actually try but I
mean is that well I'm invited
[Music]
I feel like I'm a six-year-old boys
causing trouble you